at the moment sunshine I could really do  it some more Sun the weather's been so  bad too much work probably but it's work  that I'm enjoying so that's a good thing  cooking because my cooking is pretty  atrocious and so I've set myself a task  than actually trying to make something  that's half decent rather than just  pasta kind of soggy pasta in a bowl  being on time not very good at being a  dive ma I love film so I love watching  films and I feel like you just you keep  finding new great great films and you  think how many more are there you know  you could reach the end of your life and  you won't have seen every great film  but that would be my ambition  selfishness  too much selfishness  be different be yourself which sounds  like such a cliche but but be eccentric  and weird and wear funny things and  don't try to be the same as everyone  else  you